oui c'est sûr mais les becs sur
l'essence je les trouve un peu bidon
oui tout à fait aura été donc tommy faut
jamais dire jamais j'ai fait un super
chevaux cette nuit je rêvais qu'il y
avait une forêt chèvres et là d'un coup
j'ai commencé un bel échec et c'est pas
tout un jamie je dis des trucs vraiment
chez vous dans mon vin difficile pour
moi j'ai pas de problèmes psychologiques
pour moi trouve ce trou jamie s'te plaît
tu crois que c'est grave mais non ce
n'est pas grave du tout pour comprendre
à vue mais tout ça direction le cerveau
en voiture simone
jamie c'est marcel ah oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
çà et là je crois je suis dans mon
cerveau c'est hyper grands tubes rsa
bien puisque cela page france est un
par contre jamie contextualise en trois
parties j'ai pas vu la trace d'une seule
chair et j'ai donc jamais tu pourrais
pas m'en dire un peu plus te plaît pas
de problème fois en fait le cerveau très
de l'information de différentes nations
par exemple le comptable que je me prend
dans la gueule ou la tristesse que je me
sens plus de choses dont je me rends
compte
c'est des choses que je comprends et
donc ça appartient à la conscience
d'ailleurs on dit prendre conscience de
quelque chose après c'est pas le seul
système si chic il ya le pré conscient
qui à la limite de la confiance et qui
s'apparente à peu près à ma mémoire
enfin il ya un troisième espace
psychique on a tous eu des peurs ou des
pulsions qu'on n'arrive pas trop à
expliquer je suis sûr qu a pas que moi
qui qui a fait faillite chez trt
bref il ya un troisième statistique qui
n'est ni conscient ni préconscient qui
s'appelle inconscient c'est la tension y
avoir des aperçus avec les lapsus
l'absolu ce ne sont les normands mais
aussi les actes manqués n'hésitez pas
avoir une fonction pour plus
d'informations mais aussi en analysant
les rêves comme celui de fraude avec la
chef
or faute mais ils n'ont jamais eu je me
suis un peu perdu là mais je crois que
j'ai trouvé mon inconscient monsieur
seguin mais qu'est ce que vous faites
avec cette chère mais bien sûr j'ai mis
mon rêve s'explique
mon inconscient et donc jali comment une
chose fait pour se retrouver ici dans
mon inconscient il doit y avoir plein de
trucs différents du coup ça a l'air
super large comme espace et oem ont ils
assez large commun même si toutes les
pensées ne sont pas inconscients et
c'est pas forcément donné en fait
l'activité psychique commence par la
tension et si elle veut accéder au
système consciente elle doit passer
l'épreuve de la censure si la censure
lui refuse l'accès on parle alors nos
refoulements bah voilà qui doit
d'ailleurs suite au refoulement dans
l'inconscient il nous arrive de même
plus vouloir nous souvenir de ce qu'on a
vécu
c'est le cas par exemple de sarah d'
angie angie quand elle refuse de croire
qu'elle est barry a vraiment disparu
dans le jeu je suis allé faire entendre
mon attention ce personnage que j'ai
demandé à mon pote de jouer qui le rend
complètement ridicule c'est le ca le ca
fait partie d'un système de trois
instances mouvement au phénomène qui se
passe ici qui sont le ca sur moi et moi
en fait le sap ou le prendre comme un
réservoir à pulsions et désir de là je
vais le symbolisée par une langue car
c'est l'énergie psychique
cette énergie est pas ce travers du
surmoi que symbolise ici pas un filtre
bleu sur moi c'est les barrières que tu
construis avec les par exemple les
interdits de la société médication tes
parents mais aussi t'es pas en règle
c'est ce qui fait que tu vas pas faire
l'amour avec ta copine en plein mieux là
haut
problème de sur moi c'est pour ça que
j'ai symboliser le surmoi par un filtre
bleu et du coup tu vas me demander ce
que c'est que le mois passé simple c'est
ce qui résulte du conflit entre ça et
sur moi donc ici c'est la lumière bleue
et ça me regarde
c'est la grosse teuf dans mon
inconscient un bâton plutôt bien
deuxième fois cette semaine
jamais deux sans trois à ces fraudes et
la presse armand au quai marcel denis
retour
[Musique]